[Music]
[Music]
it's never clear
whether booyah moon was always there
whether it's a kind of alternate world
an alternate reality
or whether it was actually created by
the ferocity of
scott landon's imagination
[Music]
scott and amanda both have their dark
sides they're fragile they
experience life in the world in a pretty
intense way
breumann is both really beautiful and a
very scary place my character has to go
to
booya moon to draw my inspiration
and she does too she's struggling and
that's the place that she goes
to heal
amanda is the one that really
both worlds that she really can
experience
what scots created in a very particular
way and can
navigate this reality with this world of
fiction uh this fantasy
[Music]
mrs i thought we had an agreement
seems like you don't get how serious
this business is although i think a dead
crow in the mailbox would be pretty hard
to misunderstand
i'll be seeing you
cute jimmy no missus that isn't a bit
nice
you